scott weiland of uh stone temple pilots
he was on with the stone temple pilots
are gone she just said no
he was on with velvet revolver
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes
he would do these performances one time
he did dancing days
[Music]
and i just uh thought he was fascinating
he couldn't take your eyes off him he
was so
charismatic
like the quintessential front man he's
dancing he's singing he looks great he's
got the right clothes i mean
so much goes into it
and when he would come in our studio
there was no filter there was no
phoniness about him
when you used to kiss guys on stage and
stuff and wear a dress was that to be
cool
in a way no it was it was just
completely to
shock you know we got massive so fast
you know biggest band in the world um
and we saw
our our fan base so much different from
what
it was when we were small a smaller band
you know playing and you know touring
around in an rv
and when we would play sex type thing
people weren't getting the irony
right you know and there was this like
thing with guys like you know with this
look on their face
you wanted to show them that they
shouldn't be so homophobic
yeah it was a misogynistic you know
it's like uh i mean everyone loves to
[ __ ]
i mean hopefully i mean actually some
people don't like to
he was so open and honest even about
drug use a lot of sadness right man
yeah you think that's what the whole
drug thing was shitty reached
relationship with your father
divorce you know everybody
has sadness in their lives
that's a lot of sadness to have most
people experiment
with you know alcohol marijuana
you know most people don't experiment
with heroin
right but a lot you say in your new book
that you experimented with heroin
because you thought it was sort of
opening up the creative process for any
good rock and roller well you know i
looked at
uh all the great writers you know from
the
beat generation you know the jazz
players they all did it yeah they all
did it
and uh you know it was like starting to
make its resurgence you know it's become
romanticized with artists
it was at the time you know it all kind
of ended when kurt died
i knew that he was addicted i didn't
know how severely or anything but you
just wanted to hug the guy and say
you're such a talent you're so beautiful
you're such a shining star
don't you know stay away from these
drugs please get a handle on it but you
know
it's an illness and he didn't have a
handle on it but it just saddens me
that scott weiland is gone another one
who
was just so phenomenal not only on our
show but what a great artist
[Music]
[Music]
is
tomorrow